I've helped you get to the bottom of the
list and as I pointed out this is a duel
this train you couldn't work this out in
there with a little more time okay
we have taken care of this we're taking
care of this to an extent we've written
down the products okay but I gave you a
clue before that now when you have a
look through you actually can eliminate
a significant number of these solutions
right how many can you eliminate or for
example it is actually a possibility for
the ages the answer is no because if
this were true and they both looked at
the door and the guys get sitting with
all the ages it's like oh I have enough
information this point right does that
make sense this is no longer really an
option this were here officially Jasmine
was one who's writing down the other one
look do you see this is a contender do
you notice that because at this point oh
I don't know I need more information
from a pro Marvin first now which will
return the rest of the list I've been
bought contenders there are not in fact
these two are they really that we really
need to worry about this is fun and
we're going to go through is this one
okay so we've detected we explored and
we've eliminated a lot too but there's
one more thing that's left because we've
only used two about three pieces of
information okay now which one is it and
why they all want to suggest well you
can doesn't a lot of something that's
being case 1 2 2 & 9 it has to be the
solution we can eliminate this one
because in fact and I sort of I did a
classical even a magician does photo
evolutions before which is this
direction in the third clue has nothing
to do with a violin
does it go look at the wording again
what does different letter actually say
he says the else the eldest now one of
the reasons why we use the word Z right
it's like are you are you are you a
character are you Z Gary Johnson but
there is one there is only one which
means when you have a look at this one
there is not as the eldest it recently
Elvis is only will care 23 this is the
only one which actually has out of our
final contenders which has the eldest
person there the violinist that it is
okay we're almost finished we have an
air time but I said we have to do three
themes we are dissect the question we
did that we're going to explore and live
innate the options that result once we
have the information but we need to do
this do you remember I am stuck a piece
of paper onto your desk and spaced out
you might like to pick it up turn over
and I would really hope the kind of this
before
slightly minaret in that this topics
topics like algebra trigonometry
measurement etc right but each of the
topics have a common thread through it
in fact that's fine right these four
feet these five skills you develop and
you give them over and over again just
like these three themes he are
problem-solving approaches you can use
the matter what kind of question you get
okay but what I want to exercise to do
the one at the top I mean this is what
this is all useful something done so
there's something on there but then one
of the top is the one I want to
emphasize good to the final one
communicative students develop the
ability to use a variety of
representations it written oral wrapping
form to formulate add express
mathematical ideas I'll let you read the
rest of that yourself okay how do we
done that so far I think we have right
do you see it this this is a it's a
written slash graphical way to express a
set of mathematical ideas right we're
always there that we don't quite have a
solution the last thing we need to do is
communicate like from the from the board
I think it clear what the set to three
numbers are I think it's
this is but from the board if you
submitted this to me on a piece of paper
I don't really know why you've chosen
this one versus this one right this one
over this one so we need to express this
I'm going to give you 30 seconds to
think about how would you argue how
would you present some words that
explain articulate why you chose this
ain't like Tassili solution and not this
one can you take a minute to wrap up it
down and then they'll compare it to what
you've got for me
I wonder if that was enough time that's
right so let me sort just a teeny bit
longer for you by showing you how I'm
not just answering the question I'll ask
you to do but I've also explained what
this is about
there were three sections of information
when I dissected first I just did all
the ages I did all the ages and this
table shows all the ages that answer
think that's why I was doing this but
then secondly I can further narrow it
down to either this set or this set
because they only two which have non
unique props they're the reason why the
person said I still need more
information right so I'm explaining why
I chose these two lastly when someone
likes suggest for me what they wrote
down for how you lose that one not that
one can you read their words for us in
abilities yeah click on it promising
performance it explains that there is
another one this way so I can't be one
so perfect and there's my elders Thank
You coach so in case you didn't catch
that right I think the key phrases were
since there is one eldest child right
that's the thing that sort of feed into
this one in a limit this is a
possibility right
full stop so well though